meanwhile your your fight career is
going mm-hmm what year is this now this
is uh 2000.
um
you lost your first pro fight scott
smith that was embarrassing
[Music]
and uh arrogance i fought him five weeks
before that
and like smacked him uh-huh and so i
walk into my pro debut and uh how do you
how did you beat him how did he beat you
um he beat me tko stoppage big huge cut
doctors like i can see your cheekbone
get out
um how did you beat him
three rounds of
domination domination
what'd he catch he just caught you yeah
you just went clear man he got 15
minutes of of first person preparation
and i did exactly the same thing that i
did in the first round and the first
moment of our first fight where i had a
big change level i was going to push him
up against the cage
you know make it dirty for a second so
that changed a level he just blew me
open with an uppercut
jack
like literally the exact same thing that
i i was like ah i'm gonna do the same
thing i did to him last time and he's
like i'm gonna do a different thing
and it worked out
how
when did the fight get stopped after the
first round or oh no no like like
immediately yeah
we're two minute minute minute half into
the first round
walking into the pit as a zero one
fighter
walking into gann and chuck and scott
and eric
and uh john hackleman and i already felt
like i didn't belong and now i'm walking
as an 01 pro
loser loser
what
it's like it's so crazy to think you
know even walking into that place you're
by no means yeah like you're just
walking in that place and training
you're sparring with chocoladel like
you're a bad you're a badass and yet you
get
beat you
uh you but you are moving up like moving
up the respect
ranks at the pit and you're you end up
going to some of chuck's
one of chuck's fights championship fight
um against bustamante
i was chuckling this whole time you know
anyone i don't know what it's like maybe
it's gotten better but back in the day
if you were like a teammate
you were like gonna pay your own way to
get up there you're gonna sleep with six
other guys and some you know in the same
room you weren't gonna get fed anything
you're cutting weight with your with
your fighter
it just like sucked sleeping on the
hotel room floor getting beat up by the
way you can't win any of your sparring
you're just getting beat up you're just
getting punched in the head just a bag
of blood yeah for this dude to punch
there's no there's like no glory in
being a second or a third
or a fourth which is basically what it
seemed like you were oh yes yeah yeah
they're like body get in here yeah when
eric or ganner or you know scott retired
or bored that just throwing me so i
don't even i don't even think i was like
fourth string
i was not even acknowledged in being
present did you get a ticket to the
fight because that was another thing
there was no guarantee you were getting
to the fight i didn't get a ticket to
like the first three fights i was at and
when i finally got to i think vito
belfort was the first fight that i
physically got to be
in the arena for
it was so cool yeah like we used to run
every kind of scam to get into those
fights we i i would go i would get in
every single time 100 of the time and we
were running all kinds of you know
tactical operations and i left the best
seats i got the sickest seat i've seen
so i've seen so many ufc's from like row
three that i had no tickets to we'd we
we did all kinds of tactical maneuvers
to get into those fights because because
that's the crazy thing right you'd go up
there you'd be cornering someone i would
literally be cornering someone and not
have a ticket to the fight you know but
i mean come on i'm already back there
bro yeah this just let me in
the security would walk up and be like
nine of us in front of four seats you
know they do you guys have tickets yeah
yeah yeah like this is our ticket and
they're like well that was his ticket
no no no this is my ticket well where's
his ticket like
i don't know i'm going to get a beer
i'll be back yeah
cool uh
you end up becoming the extreme
challenge champion
and in this are you starting to think
maybe this is a thing like when you when
you go up with chalk are you starting to
know still don't think about it still
don't think it's like an actual i still
like fighting
right in that that tournament that
eight-man tournament that was the who's
who of middleweights at the time
um jason mayhem miller dennis king ryan
norte me
um like
for
early 2000's when when you put like
these are the eight best dudes on the
planet because those that's that's money
right there and uh that's a tough
freaking tournament yeah and i think i
think i won enough to pay for a computer
for my next semester in school
you know like there's no money
chuck paid for my pizza kitchen
post-fight meal chuck paid for my ymca
um to go in to cut weight in the sauna
it was the only sauna we could find in
salt lake city like chuck out of pocket
like there was no money
and i'm like the ecc champion yep so
yeah those are the good old days right
there no no one was fighting for the
money back then we just fought i just
wanted to fight
uh
you fight and win in the wec as well was
that any better was there any anything
at the wec i got a hundred bucks to show
and 100 bucks to win god
to fight at a heavy weight
god you fought as a heavyweight it was a
194 pounds
and i fought as a heavyweight
you kind of get you this is kind of
you're getting like a minor level of
fame though at this point would you say
yeah like the the mma weeklies are
starting to write you know
the
up and comer you know on the top 10 top
10 rankings i'm like uh mentionable no
mentioned like notably mentioned type
categories uh so
who is this guy type questions
but
and the the wec was nothing to sneeze at
back in the day you know like i remember
it was like kind of on the same level
like ufc was obviously the bigger
promotion but you know some incredible
fighters came out at the time
i mean it was a great
great place to be at that stage yeah wc
was totally legit yeah um
you got
you you you are you getting wrapped into
the whole fighter
kind of thing right now i'm starting to
live in the booze the everything else
yeah not the booze as much
but the women the traveling the fighting
um i mean it is it's a real unhealthy
lifestyle when you're like committed to
it um you know you'd wake up you'd fight
uh no you'd wake up you'd rinse off
whatever
debauchery is on you and so you don't
carry those diseases into the gym and
then you'd go and train and then um
you'd try and do some form of recovery
and get some type of food and then
debauchery training again
and then debauchery like that's about
your day so that's so you see you were
rolling rolling rolling in that rolling
deep